okay okay oh big thanks
oh that was pretty bloody x-rated
australia's funnel web spiders have a
really bad reputation all around the
world
the most dangerous the most deadly
but is that reputation warranted well
i'm
ann jones from abc slants and today
we are watching viral videos of funnel
web spiders
the is really getting to me
while you're here if you like this sort
of video hit subscribe for more abc
science
rodeo come at me spideys i mean
i mean only on the internet open this
one up
oh wow oh hello booty
not only are they one of the world's
most venomous fires they've got to have
one of the best
threat displays i've ever seen
aggressive stance
see how fast this is
her doing her best to look big and
dangerous to a threat which is
this man so she's got her legs up
she's got her fangs out ready to strike
she's standing as big
as possible you see the drips of venom
forming on the fans there
they are known as aggressive spiders but
they're really not they're defensive
spiders they're generally only doing
this when you're playing with them or
aggravating them in some way so leave
them alone
and they probably won't attack you
unless you're a millipede more spideys
these guys are highly highly venomous
these are these sydney funnel webs
there's like 40 different
types of funnel web spiders in australia
and that's just the species we know
this spider if it did strike you could
kill you i'm going to attempt to handle
her today
oh no why the adrenaline in me is
kicking i can feel my nerves just going
why why
why no don't do that this is something
i've wanted to do for a long time
hear me australia don't do that just run
with
people so far
she's being a good girl you can actually
die really quickly if you've got a deep
envenomation from a funnel web
basically your heart and lungs stop
working just because you see it on the
internet
doesn't mean you should do it do not
handle wild spiders
it's really hard to tell which ones are
extremely dangerous and which ones
aren't
all of that being said we haven't had a
funnel web death in
yonks it's been since the 80s in
australia and that's because we've got
anti-venom because funnel webs are
incredibly lethal
if you happen to get bitten next video
i'm here filming for abc catalyst and
i'm just about to go
and find a bloke who quite ridiculously
digs up funnel web spiders for his job
let's go get him they let me out of the
studio occasionally
oh god i'm going to walk into a
spiderweb probably
and how fun we have spiders everywhere
i was on gary which is fraser island
with
some scientists and they were digging up
funnel webs and
it was insane so glenn
why would you do that because they're
beautiful number one
and their venoms are the most complex
chemical arsenals in the
entire natural world up to 3 000
molecules in the venom of a single
spider what's remarkable though is that
only one of those molecules is
responsible for the human
envenomation syndrome the thing that
kills us we're not their target though
we're just sort of
collateral damage are we we are
collateral damage so their venom is
extremely complex there's like
3 000 molecules in it and it just so
happens that there's one
in there that can really affect
us mammals they're generally preying on
insects
and phibians things like that they're
not really after us it's just sort of
like this crazy evolutionary bingo that
happened when it comes to funnel webs
and us humans oh
it's actually not that living
hello here we go
next video my son left his shoes out
over the weekend and this is why you
should always check them before putting
them back on
ah final webs in particular make a
really cool
little web array on the outside of their
burrow it's an early warning system
which you can see
around the shoe tongue oh now he's going
to poke it that's good yeah make it
angry
yeah and oh
[Music]
thought he found a really good spot when
an insect or a vibration of some sort
hits the end of the web
it goes up the webs that they've got on
the outside of their burrow and
all the way down into the sock so that
they can tell who's around
you know when you go into the milk bar
and it goes bing bing
when you go through the door it's sort
of like that
[Music]
next video hey guys
just come down to the pool no you're
surfing you need a film
i want to touch it like that
why would you touch it with your hand so
that
although it seems to be dead he's a
follow web
male he won't necessarily be dead mate
he's alive so if you come across
a funnel web and you need to move it or
capture it for some reason
make sure you get a jar that is glass or
a container that
is plastic to get them in don't try and
catch them
on a stick or a piece of paper because
they can grip onto those things
they can't grip onto smooth plastic or
smooth glass
still the best thing to do if you come
across any wild animal
is to give it a wide berth
let it do its thing it's an integral
part of the ecosystem
out there all right
is that an egg sac
[Music]
looks like it's made out of paper
doesn't it
[Music]
wow the idea of having
so many babies is basically as an
assurance that some of them will survive
if you have like 300 of them uh yeah one
of them is likely to survive
two spiders in a container and that can
only mean one thing
love the entire mating takes about five
minutes
you know he's slowly just trying to get
to her underside the female's the larger
one
male looks nervous and he should many
males don't make it out of a mating
encounter alive
you can see harry there he's just
tapping
minerva's a bit hesitant so she's
striking out a little bit just so he
keeps his distance
she was reading a good book you know she
doesn't want to be irritated by a bloke
but then he starts his little drum beats
seems minerva's finally accepting harry
what's really crazy is that the females
will stick with their one burrow for
their entire life they'll only come out
to hunt
the males however they will they will
get out
and go in search of females so that they
can mate just like what we saw there
but it does mean that there are males
wandering around
with two fistfuls of ejaculate and if
you think it was the kardashians that
made the nice round booty uh
all popular no it's not it's bloody
funnel webs look at it
nice booty
thanks for watching and if you've got a
suggestion for an animal for how deadly
leave it in a comment below catch you
next time